I literally have no words Mark for this
um we're all devastated
um as I explained before we have family
that are lost not found
um I'm currently in Cyprus I'll be
heading over to um turkey in the next
couple of days we're here uh raising
money uh sending over supplies
um and trying to find it trying to find
a route in to Turkey and to the worst
affected areas the the biggest distress
for me is that there's some areas that
have been completely flat with no help
um that's our biggest fear so what we're
trying to do here is ascertain exactly
where uh the most help is needed we've
just found out that the close is one
issue so uh literally we're reaching out
to everyone around the world everybody
that can see what's happening here with
this humanitarian disaster we're just
we're just holding our hands out for
everybody to help as much as they can as
I've said before we have family there
people dying my biggest fear there is
that
people are going to start turning on
each other I don't think the government
there is doing enough they need to step
up now and do a lot more for us and
unite as one so we can all help as much
as we can here
yeah and to me just to be clear what
you're saying you have lost family in
these earthquakes
we have a family missing in this
earthquakes that haven't been found
due to the cold weather we're not
hopeful
um we're quite worried
um yeah yeah take your time tell me yeah
um so so we're kind of here in Cyprus
this whole island has been devastated by
what's gone on here
um the the kids that haven't been found
so many people from Cyprus are over
there as well
um so many people from the UK are flying
over there as I said I'll be there as
well
um but it's just to help everyone the
fear again I keep saying is we're trying
to find a route in we know that
everything is needed from medicine water
petrol
um there's cranes I'm hearing horror
stories about cranes being parked up
there without the Manpower people don't
know how to use them
a lot of the soldiers are not have not
gone in there
and we just fear that they're you know
people are going to start turning on
each other and we just need help from
everywhere all over the world we just
need everybody to come in donate it
we've set up a page uh GoFundMe Pages
all over the world and we just you we
need to unite as one as a family to help
these people and Syria as well not just
turkey the Syrian people are suffering
as well the videos that we're watching
the children still being trapped the
cold weather
I mean it's just devastating for all of
us we're all really broken and we're all
trying to do the best we can here mark
yeah well listen I can understand that
and I'm really sorry to hear uh of your
loss and um my heart goes out to you and
just to explain
what you want to do you talk about a
funding page What specifically do you
think you want to do and what are you
asking other people to do to me
when people if people can come together
just be you know just give as much as
you can we need Manpower on the ground
now as well as money coming in money to
buy supplies but we're desperate for
Manpower we need the governments over
there to stand up to start sending the
Army in to start standing up and helping
their people like I said there's areas
there that there's no one there to help
them we're watching this stuff but
videos are being sent over from us from
uh people that are in places in grounds
that have been flattened and they're
trying to pull their families out their
families are alive but they just can't
get them out because they don't have the
Machinery they don't have the Manpower
they don't have any help they have no
food they have no water they have
nowhere to live so we just need Manpower
as well as donations we need Manpower we
need people to actually go in and stand
up put their hands under the rocks and
help these people as much as we can like
I said turkey in Syria need the world to
come together now to help them this
humanitarian disaster is like nothing
we've ever seen and we hope hope that we
never ever see it again in our lifetime
the children are absolutely and to me I
I well absolutely and I I'm just hearing
that it's been confirmed now that more
than 12 000 people have died uh in this
uh disaster so far and I look you were
talking about your family you've got
family here they must have lived and
people must live here with this fear of
of an earthquake like this because this
area is so prone to such disasters
I don't I don't think anybody living in
Turkey I mean your home's your home
there's earthquake Tremors and and
earthquakes all over the world nobody
knows how vulnerable where we're living
is
um but nobody could ever envisage or
understand that something of this
magnitude could come and hit this
country and hit these people
at such a fast pace and for it to
repeatedly come over and over again and
how catastrophic it is there you know we
really need the world to understand how
bad it is that Mark I will be with you
within the next couple of days I'll be
right by your side and then I'll be
there to do as much as I can with the
sky team with everyone else that wants
to join hand with me to come over and
help please do but none of us envisioned
this month none of us
no well of course not and um I just
wonder you mentioned about the help not
coming from the government do you are
you hearing a lot about anger here we're
certainly seeing anger here that the
government is not doing enough to help
at the moment
you you probably can see a lot more than
me Mark you probably can see a lot more
what's going on there but what we're
hearing here is that the Army is not
going in there's certain areas where
they won't go in they're not going in
these people are left on their own to
survive on their own to try and work out
on their own but the horror stories
we're hearing and I'm frightened now
that the people starting to turn on each
other people are starting to turn to
survival the cold weather the food
there's no food there's no water there's
no petrol people are freezing people are
starving and that's my biggest fear that
the people will start turning on each
other if hard fast help doesn't come
yeah well it is certainly another
freezing night uh tonight Tamir and um
there are scenes of search and rescue
going on all over this city and many
other towns and cities and
all I can do is thank you for coming on
and repeat that uh I'm very sorry for
your family lost and um I wish you well
thank you thank you very much to
everyone else who's lost as well thank
you so much and I'll see you soon yeah
yeah absolutely okay okay Tamia thank
you very much indeed